[Music]
got some good news really what's up we
need it you guys a fan of uh extinct
animals yeah oh hell yeah like the dodo
bird
interesting they'll bring them
where do you say that is that the cause
you know what dota bird's so popular
when you think of extinct animals that's
the first thing i think of [ __ ]
dinosaurs
but that's not that's not is that
something
okay dude you're going to call an
amphibian or some [ __ ] on me i'm not
stupid
i'm just saying i like [ __ ] dinosaurs
i do think of dinosaurs too okay thank
you i know what's going on
are they doing a re-release
what is this a [ __ ] shoe was it a
dinosaur they found something fully
intact and some ice yeah we covered that
dinosaur oh mosquito with dinosaur
blood in a mosquito on amber and then
the guy put it on a [ __ ] cane and
then they made a movie it is yeah it was
a documentary
documentary
yeah
i they absolutely are but
for the dodo bird really they have now
finished sequencing the dota bird's dna
and they can bring it back why do we do
[ __ ] look man i don't want to get on a
high horseshoe do it do it do it
take my extinct horse get on that one
but like we got like cancer and we got
wars and we got all this stuff going on
and these animals probably died for a
reason that wasn't humans especially
dodos did oh we killed them
they got they got eaten too much they
were like they were smart enough all
right i'm an idiot but either way we
still got cancer and they're also
different departments the food
department okay okay tony like [ __ ]
the football team
has nothing to do with it
has all the information it's not like
they're talking about one group of
scientists no but resources but
resources and instead we're going to try
to just [ __ ] create life
well that sounds kind of nice when you
say it like that yeah
i got away with words
i agree with you where i feel like when
was the last time adult alberto was
alive like over 100 years who cares yeah
i thought there was some dinosaur type
[ __ ] but if the airplanes killed him i'm
way off
1662.
can i see what they look like the reason
why i disagree is because
i agree with you thanks dude because uh
it's been centuries right we have an
evolved ecosystem and now you're
bringing in a new predator a new place
let's all replicate uh the play movies
there's movies about this
bring back uh
we should bring it back let's bring up
kangaskhan and also the plague
yeah all that we show it's like a one
for once like you guys are gonna bring
dodo bird back you better bring me a
genghis khan
at least
so that sounds stupid but joking aside
when do we draw the line who draws the
line on what creature we can recreate
but don't get used to drawings
but don't you guys want to eat it
because that's what i do that's why i
like some duck i want to be his friend i
think the reason i look at this fat
[ __ ] i want to eat it oh i think
one of the reasons
they feel compelled to bring it back is
because humans are responsible for it
oh humans are creations reparations but
i'm sure we killed a lot of things wait
what do we do so many things
at all how many people big bad people
when it got when they just got eaten
yeah it's because like when they got to
the island where the dodo bird is
they never had a predator so they don't
have any fears so when humans walk up to
it they're just chilling next to you and
they're like they thought the birds were
stupid because they never ran away so if
they're hungry they grabbed them and
then
you know humans brought dogs they
brought other animals and then they
would you know basically
colonize the island it's the tiger and
life of pie with the meerkats
if anybody remembers that also the
dodo's environment that it was from is
still in existence so they could just
put it right back
like the t-rex like the eco system
they're scared
that's a little different from a t-rex
time yeah oh yeah yeah
but i still but agree like joking aside
why aren't we cloning [ __ ] then
and also if we're in global you gotta
buy more heads
wouldn't it be kind of hot for the dodo
now that's a good point who cares for
400 seconds
the environment it was from is still
sustainable i think that also means the
dodo might be okay i do think we should
bring back the delta bird because it's
very notorious and we haven't even lived
with it for like 400 years and it's a
funny name that is pretty cool to bring
it back though
if all the people what if it's [ __ ] up
and none of us know what if it's racist
by nature carries aids or some [ __ ]
they're going to bring it back with aids
they're just going to put aids back what
do we know like a racist donor
what do we know
how about we let the dodo bird come back
it's hard to argue with that face when
you're like what do we know we have a
bunch of idiots they're gonna clone it
and train it and put it back or how is
that i don't know about training it's
actually not decided yet if they're
gonna do it but they just wanted to tell
you that they can't
high five five five what's up kimura
kamura chimera that isn't that a
mythical yeah
i thought it's like when we when we mess
[ __ ] oh like a snake's like a hybrid
like a like a lynx
no no
like a liger like a light girl there
have been ligers before not too but like
human and like a human in a pig
and they'd be cloning it in a little
petri dish
like a centaur yeah
come
yeah it would be like a beast made up of
different parts the chimera had like
wings but like a lion lion head or body
or something that's a griffin no i think
a griffin is a chimera i think a camera
is like the
oh
yeah i think we do [ __ ] like that all
right what about a gargoyle
that was a dope show
yes sunset all right street sharks the
sun's coming up
also a dope show all right how did we
make sure let's clone it all [ __ ]
i do believe in the two strike rule so
if we bring this [ __ ] back right
and this [ __ ] gets it extinct
again nah two strike rule
baseball
you're too dumb to exist is that how you
feel about pandas not wanting to breed
if they get extinct and we bring them
back and they get extinct again [ __ ]
them
because they're not they're not horny
enough
yeah
you killed all of us like we were in
valhalla
memories the memories aren't yeah
everybody if it's that way like right
when they're done he goes
[Laughter]
how about they don't bring back but they
create creatures that we've been hearing
about like the phoenix
it's not so dangerous where's the dna
the dragon
what is a female what the [ __ ] is that a
dragon it's a rapper isn't it a rapper
i like dragons
they look like dinosaurs okay first of
all i think if we're gonna bring back
something that we're clearly under it on
the food chain maybe that's not a good
idea that's what they were yeah that's
why we're starting here yeah they were
just people were dodo dragon
what the [ __ ] a dragon
every time someone says it mike's like
what the [ __ ] it's a dragon correct yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa japanese
we could do chinese dragons they don't
eat humans yeah you ride them and [ __ ]
right i mean dragon balls you can good
luck bro you ride them and [ __ ] they
grant you wishes yeah but they
disappeared other like [ __ ]
frequencies and stuff so you might get
lost i have another contingency yes we
bring these [ __ ] back and we
zoom up
zoom up yeah all the zoos get lock them
up
they don't get one yeah
with zooed up dodos don't mean like it
tastes good then all of a sudden kfc is
gonna mass breed him or something right
oh a little fried dodo that's what i'm
saying if it was a flavor profile that
was like yo dodo it's crazy
oh like [ __ ] scriptures that we find
and [ __ ] like that the daughter was the
tastiest of the [ __ ] bird
kingdom dodo nuggies tons of poo mommy
bro
they're like the truffles of [ __ ] you
know
turducken
so that is what they said about uh
dinosaurs when they were asked like why
don't you do it with t-rexes and they
were like because there's no habitat for
them to live like they would just run
amok but they thought about that how
would they just frighten him stupid
mammoth that would be cool oh you'd like
that the woolly man was right don't they
live in some ice aren't they herbivores
yeah that's what i mean this is a harry
elephant
like they're so big brontosauruses [ __ ]
chewing up trees and walking all slow
i think it's a long skull bear or
something that's the one you want have
you seen that those are crazy oh yeah
it's extinct right the long nose right
yeah long nose bear i think that [ __ ]
long skull same thing their skull is
longer they pull up a picture of a long
nose bear yeah they're like way bigger
than that
15 feet yeah those ice age animals look
crazy though
humans ate a lot of woolly mammoth like
that was their [ __ ] that they changed
yeah like the whole winner yeah
anthony to your point though what the
[ __ ] your brontosaurus
i think we kill enough of our own trees
we don't need no tree eaters yeah
suddenly you're getting all righteous on
me when you want to put [ __ ] dodos
and chains and [ __ ] and shoes right away
i'm not in chains just zoom up dude
with nice little ceilings
okay what other animal that could you
could bring back from the past that you
would zoo up i mean that's the whole
dragon yeah that's literally the dragon
you ever seen the glyptodon what's up is
that what that is no that's definitely
an animator
that's definitely still a thing it's
uci's mascot that's my penis yeah yeah
it looks like that they got to bring
back saber-toothed tigers it doesn't
yeah oh that'd be tight are you sure
it's called long nose bear all the power
how about i just go through extinct
bears have you seen the giant sasquatch
looking ones the big giant is bigfoot
will we bring him back oh yeah bring him
back
gigantopithecus that thing again it's
epithecus have you seen those those are
15 feet and dope
here's a good scale jefferson's grand
sloth a dire wolf dyer
sure yeah that's sick there's a short
face bearing well there's a camera a
western cat that's what it is
giant slime we're so fun concave face
bear a hagerman horse you see that's
half zebra half horse that's cool he's
searching something damn dude we used to
have camels yeah were you looking at
pokemon yeah he's like dude we should
definitely bring back charmanders
let's bring it back and see no man see
let's let's do that let's make pokemon
what about insane that'd be tight that'd
be tight yeah the horror movie where
they accidentally [ __ ] up is it this
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah bro look at that whoa
that thing is huge no let's not bring it
that bad it's not a sloth we do not need
to bring that back it's an extinct bear
that uh knows bear
short short nose short face shirt it's
called short nose but his nose is long
dude it's the irony
during the ice age there was way way
bigger [ __ ] animals right but then
there was humans too it's way better
than clubs but the humans weren't bigger
bring back the animals the weapons of
like i heard they're actually similar
size i heard it's a big myth that we
were so small did you hear that from an
anthropologist yeah no you did it
[Music]
you